given how Wild and unpredictable the
world can be wouldn't life be so much
easier if we could see into the future
imagine being able to look ahead and
know what good or bad thing is about to
come around the corner if times have
been hard for you knowing you've got
something worth looking forward to might
give you just enough willpower to keep
going or if there's a storm on the
horizon then at least you would have
enough time to prepare unfortunately
being able to Glimpse at future events
is a power that only a few if any of us
are blessed with ask a senate and they
might tell you that seeing the future is
an ability reserve for scammers and con
artists at Fairgrounds or selling out
magic shows in Las Vegas all people just
trying to make a quick Buck by telling
they're paying customers what they want
to hear you can't part the Cloudy Veil
that hangs over the future for free
after all and then there are fortune
cookies those crispy sugary treats you
crack open after a meal usually
containing a piece of paper with some
pre-written generic aphorism or a vague
prophecy if a human being can't look
into the future then surely those
ambiguous predictions printed on Tiny
slips of paper and left inside of
fortune cookies could never be accurate
right Sage was one of those cynics sure
some might argue he had every right to
be having fallen on some pretty hard
times things weren't exactly running
smoothly and his life certainly had not
taken the direction that he hoped it
would the trouble had started when quite
unexpectedly his landlord had raised the
rent on his apartment Sage had been
struggling to make ends meet at work
already and the increase in those
monthly payments meant his hands were
time eventually he had no choice but to
move out forced by the increase in rent
to leave the apartment he had once
called home the one Saving Grace was
that is France Ash and Joey had offered
him a place to stay as long as Sage
could throw them a little bit of money
to cover their own rent it was way less
than his old landlord was asking for
however even that came with the
unfortunate downside the caveat that
Sage would have to sleep on their couch
instead of having his own room sure not
the worst thing in the world but it does
beat the floor but for sage it was far
from an ideal living situation to try
and lessen the blow having to leave the
independence and privacy of his own
place Joey and Ash had decided amongst
themselves to throw a little celebratory
dinner but of course the key oversight
to their plan was that neither of them
were all that great at cooking mostly
surviving on either ordering and
delivery from local fast food places or
anything that only needed a quick nuking
in the microwave in order to make edible
all the same Ash was adamant that their
lack of culinary know-how wasn't going
to stand in their way he and his fellow
roommates were going to lay on a slap up
fees for their down on his luck friend
Sage the only way they knew how by
ordering takeout it's food he remarked a
little loss for words after having seen
his two new roommates excitedly yelling
surprise at him the moment he walked
through the door not just any food Joey
replied grinning like a maniac it's
welcome to the apartment food you wanted
to celebrate me sleeping on your couch
Sage said staring at the mountains of
white paper oyster pails on the table
with red Mandarin lettering and ancient
temples painted on the sides by ordering
Chinese food he added with confusion
look you've been going through it man
Ash cut in explaining things that Sage
already knew so we figured this might
lift your spirits check it out we've got
it all here man dumplings noodles the
works and for after he produced a small
box the brand name La Choy emblazoned on
its surface inside were 12 fortune
cookies all individually wrapped for
freshness as the writing on the box
boasted hey maybe you'll get some good
news from one of these Joey smiled
pointing at the box I
thanks guys Sage eventually said
chuckling quietly to himself he had to
admit what his friends were trying to do
for him albeit a little excessive came
from a place of good intentions little
did any of them know he was about to
change the very course of their lives
their fortunes forever nearly two hours
and several pounds of greasy Chinese
takeout later the trio of roommates were
starting to wonder whether or not this
Feast had been a good idea but it
started as an innocent meal now had them
all feeling a little queasy having eaten
so much food that they were questioning
their life choices and still with a few
oyster pails half full of leftover food
throwing out the empty paper containers
and leaving the rest in the fridge Sage
sat back on the sofa groaning in tandem
with his friends and cursing himself for
having a third helping of the chili beef
ah damn I almost forgot Joey said weekly
reaching for the box of fortune cookies
opening it he offered it to Sage who
immediately put up his hands to refuse
no way if I eat another thing ice where
I might have a heart attack he said we
don't actually have to eat them Ash
interjected picking up one of the
plastic wrapped cookies at random you
only open them for the fortunes anyway
right and I guess one of these cookies
is gonna tell me that everything happens
for a reason or to keep my head up for
some other vague non-specific prediction
Sage replied making no attempt to mask
his sarcasm come on man Joey urge taking
a cookie for himself before thrusting
the box into Sage's hands sure they're
never perfectly accurate but it's just a
bit of fun besides it's all down to how
you interpret your fortune you aren't
meant to take it literally with a
cynical size Sage gave in and grabbed
one of the remaining fortune cookies
tearing open the plastic packaging
surrounding it in time with Ash and Joey
doing the same he then snapped the
yellow sugary shell in two a tiny piece
of paper was concealed within with an
inscription printed on one side in blue
ink but before he had a chance to read
it Joey who was sitting next to him and
had done just the same recited his own
fortune out loud buy a ticket trust your
instinct and the numbers will come he
read no way that's what it says Ash
argued I'm not kidding Joey protested
let me guess the other side reads this
Fortune was sponsored by the state
lottery Sage joke indignantly Joey held
up his fortune to his friends faces
letting them read for themselves what he
had already repeated aloud being far
from a betting man Joey had hardly ever
made as little as a friendly low stakes
wager let alone taking the chance on
playing either the state lottery or a
national one like the Powerball the odds
of winning just seemed like they were
stacked too high and yet something about
just how specific this Fortune was made
Joey feel compelled to maybe give it a
try considering taking a chance and
playing against those odds by buying
himself a ticket my turn Ash announced
excitedly unfolding her own paper
fortune and clearing her throat keep
your light on the person you're looking
for will be here soon even someone as
cynical as Sage had to admit there was
something very strange about how
detailed these fortunes had been or
seemed to be at least partisan thought
maybe that was part of their gimmick
making the text on the paper that little
bit less vague and generic than the
other ones found in other cookies so
that people would find it easier to
believe they were an accurate prediction
of the future but then again it did seem
like a strange coincidence Sage knew
that Ash had been trying to get back
into the dating scene but was having
little luck on the more popular apps for
meeting new people still it's not like
the prediction on that little piece
would actually come true nor would
Joey's but if nothing else the Lisa
could do was inspire a little hope in
the pair of them Sage looked down at his
own fortune part of him secretly wanting
there to be another optimistic message
written on the paper after all he needed
a little boost in that department even
if it was just for tonight printed in
blue ink were three short words look
both ways Sage Red immediately feeling
his hard drop in disappointment that one
sounds way vager Joey commented
highlighting the obvious well we can't
all pick the nice fortunes Sage retorted
crunching the tiny slip of paper up in
his hand and stuffing it into his back
pocket they're all just randomly
generated anyway or probably a million
fortunes out there that are all worded
exactly the same as ours it's not like
any of these will come true anyway
falling asleep on the couch later that
night sage had no idea just how wrong he
was about to be proven almost to the
same degree he had little clue as to
what his fortune had actually meant but
would only realize when it was too late
over the course of the following few
months a lot seemed to be happening in
the lives of Sage's two friends and by
contrast very little was changing in his
own life the first surprise came when
Ash had met a new flame a Girl by the
name of Skye in Sage's head it was just
a fling not something he expected to
last although he would think twice about
saying it out loud so as to not accept
his roommate but to his surprise Ash
seemed to be utterly smitten with her
Newfound relationship the pair of them
were happy the very textbook definition
of head over heels for one another both
sage and Joey were quick to voice their
support but seeing what Ash's fortune
cookie had predicted actually coming to
pass got the latter of them thinking had
that just been a lucky coincidence was
it just a case of right place right time
Joey wasn't entirely convinced despite
Sage telling him otherwise as far as he
was concerned it was all just down to
timing and confirmation bias something
that was impossible to predict or
foresee had happened that it just so
happened to coincide with what they had
read in their fortune cookies but for
his friend it seemed an awful lot like
the fortune Ash had picked was 100
percent accurate which meant he could be
two on top of that Joey couldn't help
but Wonder had the fortunes inside the
cookies predicted what was already going
to happen or did reading those
predictions make them become a reality
eager to find out if his own fortune
cookie had been telling the truth Joey
decided to make a spontaneous Venture on
his way home from work while riding the
subway he opened up the website for the
Powerball and went about purchasing a
ticket the minimum bet was only a few
dollars but if his cookie prophecy was
really a guaranteed accurate forecast of
the future then Joey was in for good
fortune in every literal sense of the
word his paper slip had told him to put
Faith in his own instincts and so with
Trembling Hands he input a series of
numbers going with the first ones that
popped into his head getting back to the
apartment that night Joey's heart was
racing and he made sure to let the
others know about it barely able to
contain his excitement through the pure
unfiltered nervousness his friend was
exhibiting quickly became unbearable to
Sage the draw for the Powerball was fast
approaching at the end of the week
although he was getting sick of Joey
claiming his numbers were sure to be
called and pondering out loud what he
would spend the prize money on Sage's
cynicism still prevented him from
believing that his friend was going to
win despite having witnessed Ash's
Fortune come true already it wasn't
until it happened right in front of his
eyes that Sage started to realize just
how wrong he might have been the night
of the draw the three roommates plus the
new Love of Ash's life were gathered
around the TV all of them apart from
Sage were glued to the screen barely
breathing the apartment was so quiet you
could hear a pin drop the silence only
broken by Sage occasionally piping up
watch it's not actually going to come
true he would assert not intending to
put a downer on the proceedings but
merely trying to encourage Joey to
manage his expectations the other three
shushed him the numbers were about to be
called gripping his ticket in one hand
the paper slip containing the fortune in
the other Joey felt his pulse Rising
heart bumping against his chest he
wasn't sure if it was out of excitement
or nerves in fact it was more likely an
even blend of both on the screen the
multi-colored balls were pulled one by
one out of a spinning chamber each one
marked with a different number slowly
the first was revealed to the audience
Joey Ash and her partner Skye could
hardly contain their excitement when
they saw that it was the same is the
first number Joey had picked out it was
only when the second number was called
and the others once again yelped in
excitement so loudly that Sage looked up
from his phone and took notice before
his very own eyes he watched as each
number that the Powerball presenter
unveiled was met with a chorus of more
and more excited whooping from his
friends they were all a perfect match
for Joey's numbers every single one he
had won a huge sum of money exactly as
the fortune cookie had alluded to even
for someone as skeptical and
disbelieving of predicting the future it
was hard for sage to deny that both of
his roommate's fortunes had come true in
fact it was especially hard to be
cynical about it after watching
firsthand as Joey won the Powerball by
trusting his instincts which boiled down
to him literally picking the first
numbers that randomly came into his hand
but given how specific both Joey's and
Ash's personal prophecies had been
compared to how vague his own was Sage
didn't know if what his slip of paper
had said was a promise of good things to
come or an ominous warning it also
didn't help that he just couldn't nail
down what it meant look both ways for
weeks and weeks on end he mulled the
phrase over in his head it didn't make
sense for it to be completely literal
leading Sage to try and think of more
metaphorical interpretations of his
fortune he thought maybe there was
something political about it that it
might be urging him to consider both of
America's two parties more equally when
casting a vote rather than just blindly
ticking a box but the next election was
still years away meanwhile the
predictions of ashes and Joey's fortune
cookies had already come to pass in the
six months since they had first opened
them frustrated and looking for the
exact answer behind his paper fortune
Sage was running out of ways to
reinterpret those three words that
apparently dictated his inevitable fate
but the thing that pushed him into pure
desperation was the uncontrollable
jealousy of witnessing just how happy
his friends were after their fortunes
became true he wanted to be happy for
them and tried best to be but seeing Ash
and sky in their Blissful relationship
and Joey frivolously spending his
Powerball winnings on expensive clothing
soon became unbearable having exhausted
all other options still no closer to
understanding what his fortune was Sage
decided to visit the Chinese restaurant
they had ordered their food from all
those months ago but it's hard sank as
the staff working in the restaurant told
him that whatever was written in the
fortune cookies didn't have any bearings
in the real world you don't understand
Sage argued my friends both had their
fortunes come true I mean the cookies we
got from you predicted it almost
perfectly down to the word I just need
you to tell me what mine means I'm sorry
sir the young man behind the counter
applied but it must just be a
coincidence fortune cookies can't
accurately tell the future it's more
about what you believe the fortune means
disheartened Sage left the restaurant
his head hanging low as he walked down
the street towards the sidewalk he felt
his phone vibrate in this pocket taking
a look at the screen still walking he
saw a text from Joey he was asking if
Sage had any luck asking the restaurant
about his fortune cookie maybe if Sage
had done with a fateful slip of paper
I'd told him as he stepped off the
sidewalk then he would have seen the bus
speeding down the road towards him if
you want to know the future perhaps you
should only look at your own risk
sometimes knowing exactly what is
destined to happen to you can make it
impossible to avoid a self-fulfilling
prophecy if you will that is the warning
given to any who dares to take a
prediction from
scp-377 now residing in the personal
break room at one of the SCP
foundation's sites
scp-377 is the designation given to an
anomalous box of fortune cookies the
fact that the box is seemingly capable
of Replay punishing itself at regular
intervals refilling every 12 hours
happens to be the far less interesting
thing about it any of the fortune
cookies taken from
scp-377r well the cookies themselves are
completely Ordinary by any and all
metrics they taste exactly as fortune
cookies should and they aren't made of
any ingredients apart from those you'd
expect but somehow without fail every
single Fortune found within one of these
crispy confectionary Clairvoyance
manages to be 100 accurate they aren't
generalized predictions for the future
definitely none of them have prophesized
who the next winners of the World Series
are going to be or who is next in line
to be president every Fortune contained
in the scp-377 cookies are specifically
tailored to the person who opens them
these fortunes have ranged from detailed
foreknowledge of upcoming events and
changes in someone's personal life to
vague unspecified Illusions to what lies
ahead and while always factually
accurate and perfectly aligned with the
future the predictions made by these
cookies are not always Promises of Good
Fortune One researcher opened up an
scp-377 fortune cookie only to read the
phrase It's a boy written on the paper
less than an hour later his wife's water
broke and said researcher was soon
welcoming his newborn baby son into the
world but another doctor was warned you
don't have long to live right before
choking on his own cookie right there in
the break room that doctor suffocated
killed by the same thing that foretold
of his death only moments before it is
for that reason that SCP Foundation
Personnel are given a warning before
helping themselves to a sugary shelled
treat all staff are permitted to open a
cookie from scp-377 after all they are
safe to eat and Foundation employees are
also welcome to read their fortunes
however they only do so at their own
risk now go and check out scp-261
pan-dimensional vending machine and
scp-348 a gift from Dad if you're still
feeling for more appetizing anomalies
and snack-worthy scps to satiate your
hunger